téva 20h avec roger gicquel après les
obsèques de hans martin schleyer les
nations unies ouvre le dossier du
terrorisme
yvon bourges en urss les soviétiques ont
dévoilé pour lui leurs armements les
plus modernes écoles privées même statut
que l'école publique la loi guermeur
voté par le sénat
rapatrié 190 mille dossiers concernés
par le projet de loi d'indemnisation
approuvé demain en conseil des ministres
bonsoir obsèques nationales pour le
président du patronat allemand ce matin
à stuttgart
plusieurs milliers de policiers pour
garder l'église sainte et bras ou le
président de la république valter shell
le chancelier schmitt des ministres des
hommes politiques des représentants
étrangers christian bonnet pour la
france
800 invités au total allait assister à
la messe de requiem retransmise par deux
chaînes de télévision
dans ces conditions et dans le climat
actuel en allemagne on conçoit que des
mesures de sécurité exceptionnelles
était éprise
le président et le chancelier était
protégé par un rideau de gardes du corps
c'est encore une image de cette
allemagne marquées par le la peur du
terrorisme dont le président de la
république monsieur shell devait faire
le centre de son éloge funèbre dans le
silence de l'église sainte hébrard on
entendit c'est terrible parole si la
flamme du terrorisme n'était pas
étouffer attend elle se répandrait dans
le monde entier comme un feu de brousse
bernard wolker la présence du ministre
français de l'intérieur aux obsèques de
monsieur hans martin schleyer à toucher
l'opinion publique allemande
monsieur christian bonnet était la seule
personnalité étrangère présente à ses
obsèques
et le geste du gouvernement français a
été apprécié par le gouvernement
allemand dans son éloge funèbre le
président de la république monsieur
walter schels a tout d'abord demandé
pardon à la famille de monsieur flyers
sacrifier pour raison d'état mais il a
aussi attaqué les assassins j'ai honte
de leur méchanceté at il dit ils sont
fiers de pouvoir voler et assassinées
ces jeunes gens perdus sur les ennemis
de toute civilisation la lutte contre le
terrorisme et la lutte contre la
barbarie a dit monsieur celle qui a
conclu en lançant un appel à tous les
pays du monde à tous les gouvernements
pour la mise au point d'une convention
anti terroriste l'inhumation de monsieur
hans martin flyers a eu lieu dans
l'après midi au cimetière de si longue
ou proches 202 bis cérémonie intime à
m'excuser la famille et seuls étaient
présents les nombreux amis du président
du patronat pour eux et pour les
allemands dans la grande majorité
hans martin schleyer est devenu un
symbole de la lutte antiterroriste
jamais sans doute bader et ses émules
n'ont été autant rejetés par leurs
concitoyens
toutes classes sociales confondues
qu'aujourd'hui
ouais
m
au même moment dans toutes les
entreprises allemandes grands et petits
les ouvriers ont cessé le travail
pendant trois minutes au congrès des
syndicats à munich tous les participants
ont fait de même devant le cercueil de
monsieur flyers les pleurs de sa femme
et de ses enfants
les allemands ont constaté qu'entre les
terroristes aient eu c'était ouvert un
abîme infinie et mortelle les mauvaises
images bien sûr sur la double enquête
pour retrouver les terroristes dont les
noms et les visages sont affichés
partout et sur les conditions de la mort
des trois 2/3 des extrémistes en prison
il n'y a rien de bien nouveau ce soir la
plus grande chasse à l'homme qu'on n'ait
jamais vu en allemagne s'est poursuivie
aujourd'hui sans qu'aucune arrestation
notoire net eu lieu quatre cent
cinquante mille personnes et autant de
véhicules ont été contrôlés en trois
jours il ya eu à peu près 200
interpellations mais la police allemande
estime que les terroristes sont encore à
l'étranger
et justement en france l'enquète se
poursuit mais les uns après les autres
les témoignages recueillis et qui
tentait de dire qu' il y avait on avait
aperçu des terroristes ces témoignages
sont écartés des recherches ont eu lieu
dans les environs de nancy aujourd'hui
la police française estime elle que les
ravisseurs de schreyer ne sont pas
restés en france après son assassinat
des mesures sévères de contrôle ont été
prises dans plusieurs régions de la
frontière franco allemande mais la
frontière franco-suisse dans la région
que nous avons nous avons montré hier
est toujours aussi perméable
enfin à paris attentats contre les
locaux du syndicat de la magistrature
gros dégâts il s'agit à l'évidence d'une
action d'extrême droite
demain la police a décidé d'interdire
une manifestation du parti des forces
nouvelles devant l'ambassade d'allemagne
ainsi qu'une manifestation d'extrême
gauche qui en effet risques
d'affrontement entre ces deux groupes
tout le monde a remarqué les égards
exceptionnelle qui ont été réservées par
les soviétiques à notre ministre de la
défense yvon bourges tout le monde l'a
remarqué y compris les communistes
français qui s'en inquiète
en effet l'accueil fait à notre ministre
de la défense a été particulièrement
attentionné non seulement il s'est
entretenu pendant une heure et demie
avec leonid brejnev mais encore il a eu
le privilège de visiter le centre
spatial de baïkonour et houlès où les
occidentaux admis avant lui avait été le
général de gaulle et georges pompidou
est seul mais il a pu aussi avoir un
aperçu très complet des dernières
réalisations soviétique en matière
d'armement à kiev il a vu toute la série
des mig y compris le mig 25 et d'autres
avions modernes et surtout il a pu voir
le nouveau char t72 que seuls les
officiers soviétique connaissent et que
les chefs militaires des autres pays de
l'est n'ont pas encore vu vous allez
donc voir pour la première fois au monde
ce nouveau char soviétique t 72 grâce à
jean-pierre guitare qui était du voyage
en urss
nous sommes ici à 45 km à l'ouest de
moscou très exactement au siège de la
division taman une division de la gare
d'une division qui s'est
particulièrement illustré lors de la
dernière guerre manque le ministre de la
défense monsieur yvon bourges a donc
visité regarder ces différents matériels
qui nous ont étaient présentes et
notamment c'est une surprise et une
surprise de taille
c'est une exclusivité mondiale les
soviétiques ont fait découvrir au
ministre français de la défense et donc
à l'équipe de tf1
le dernier né de leur plein des le char
t72 malgré son poids quarante et une
tonne le t-72 avance à une vitesse
proche de 100 kilomètres/heure et son
autonomie dépasse les 500 kilomètres il
est servi par un équipage de trois
hommes et son armement se compose d'un
canon lisse de 125 mm et de deux
mitrailleuses
en outre et c'est peut-être le plus
important il peut s'en tirer lui-même en
quelques minutes grâce à une pelle
mécanique situé à l'avant du châssis
outre ce char les spécialistes français
ont été particulièrement impressionnés
par les véhicules d'appuyer de transport
de troupes qui sont l'environnement
naturel des blindés armés de miss
ces véhicules ont une mobilité et une
puissance de feu inconnu en europe
occidentale et d'après certains
observateurs leur emploi auprès des thés
72 bouleverse complètement les théories
actuelles sur l'emploi de l'armé blindée
au total neuf types de matériels parmi
les plus modernes et les plus
performantes été présenté à monsieur
yvon bourges la division taman n'était
qu'une des étapes d'un voyage auquel les
soviétiques ont voulu donner un
caractère exceptionnel
les soviétiques ont voulu que les
relations entre les armées française et
soviétiques caractérise soit
caractérisée également par ce sentiment
de compréhension et d'amitié et je vous
vois ce que c'est ce qui explique les
conditions dans lesquelles le excellente
dans lesquelles s'est accompli ce voyage
pour les soviétiques les relations avec
la france sont exemplaires
je l'espère je suis en tout cas tout à
fait persuadé que le gouvernement
soviétique
ll y attache un intérêt tout particulier
oui je vous ai dit que les communistes
français n'apprécient menaces n'ont pas
apprécié la qualité de l'accueil réservé
en urss à yvon bourges on pouvait lire
ce matin dans l'humanité les lignes
suivantes
on remarque que c'est le deuxième membre
du gouvernement français à être reçu par
léonid brejnev en trois semaines la fois
précédente c'était monsieur bart bien
qu'il s'y fût alors présenté les mains
vides le premier ministre s'était
employé à tirer parti de ces rencontres
à des fins électoralistes fin de
citation mais l'essentiel du côté de la
place du colonel fabien aujourd'hui
c'est la grande campagne d'information
et d'explication que le pc a décidé de
lancer dans tout le pays pour réaliser
l'union c'est le thème
cette campagne sera d'une envergure
exceptionnelle 25000 rencontres débats
sont prévus dans toute la france ce qui
n'est pas rien à organiser dans les six
semaines qui viennent georges marchais
participera à neuf meetings et 40 autres
rassemblements seront animées par de
grands responsables du pc le secteur
propagande du parti va être renforcé par
cinq membres du comité central un
service svp informations et mises en
place un budget de 10 millions de francs
est prévu cette campagne est évidemment
à placer dans la suite logique de la
rupture de la gauche une formidable
compétition est désormais ouverte entre
le parti socialiste et le parti
communiste metz
surtout l'état major du pc doit avoir
senti la nécessité d'informer sa base
qui ne comprend toujours pas les vraies
raisons de la rupture de son côté le
parti socialiste annonce une campagne
nationale d'adhésion à la mi novembre
l'organisation d'expositions sur les
propositions socialistes dans toutes les
villes de france et 21 meetings en un
mois le premier le 10 novembre à lyon
avec françois mitterrand égalité de
traitement pour l'école libre et pour
l'école publique de la part de l'état
telle est le sens de la loi sur
l'enseignement privé la loi guermeur du
nom de son auteur député rpr du
finistère
le texte déjà adopté par les députés en
juin dernier a été adopté définitivement
aujourd'hui par les sénateurs 174 voix
contre 104 et sans modification du texte
je rappelle que l'école privée l'école
libre compte deux millions d'élèves soit
20% des effectifs scolaires jakin
collins cette loi qui a été votée par
l'assemblée le 29 juin dernier complète
et actualise la loi debré de 1959
elle prévoit la participation au
financement des écoles privées
l'aide de l'état qui concernait jusqu'à
maintenant uniquement les salaires des
professeurs et les frais de
fonctionnement des écoles s'étendra
désormais à l'équipement et à la
construction par exemple la construction
des ateliers de technologie rendu
nécessaire par la réforme haby les
statuts des maîtres du privé seront
alignés sur ceux du public âge de la
retraite droit à la formation continue
et cetera pour sauvegarder leur
indépendance la nomination des maîtres
restera la seule responsabilité des
chefs d'établissement et non des
recteurs
ceci pour éviter que des maîtres nommé
de l'extérieur n'est pas les mêmes
convictions que l'école et détruisent
ainsi de fait le caractère propre et
notamment religieux d'un établissement
l'enseignement privé gardera la
possibilité de former ses propres
enseignants dans des centres privés
enfin la gestion des établissements sous
contrat restera autonome sous contrôle
évidemment mais sans main mise de l'état
c'est donc une loi qui a été très
minutieusement préparée dans le calme
pas du tout une loi électoralistes en la
loi que nous voulons n'est pas pour
détruire l'école publique bien au
contraire j'ai passé moi même mon
certificat d'études à l'école publique
c'est vous dire que je
rien contre l'enseignement public non
c'est une loi qui a fait une loi de
justice sociale pour les maîtres qui
sont cent mille cent mille travailleurs
à qui on va donner l'égalité avec leurs
collègues de l'enseignement public
c'est aussi une loi de liberté pour les
familles qui doivent pouvoir choisir en
fonction de leurs convictions
l'éducation de leurs enfants sans avoir
à payer plus pour cela que s'ils
envoyaient leurs enfants dans
l'enseignement public
et puis c'est une loi de sécurité pour
les écoles que l'on ne pourra plus
nationalisée dans l'ombre sur un simple
morceau de papier mais qui sera protégé
contre les atteintes aussi bien de
l'extérieur que de l'intérieur et je
crois qu'au fond on peut dire que cette
loi fait respecter le contrat moral qui
est passé au sein de la communauté
éducative c'est à dire entre les maîtres
les parents et les élèves et je crois
que c'est ça la liberté à 13 heures vous
avez pu assister un face à face entre
deux présidents de fédérations de
parents d'élèves m cornec et monsieur
lagarde une empoignade d'homme à homme
qui se sont accusés mutuellement d'avoir
voulu politiser ces élections eh bien ce
n'est pas beaucoup éclairer le débat
pour les parents d'élèves qui je le
rappelle élisent leurs conseils dans les
maternelles et les primaires comme le
dispose la réforme haby renseignements
pratiques
ce sont les chefs d'établissement qui
organise les votes donc renseignez vous
dans chaque école mais pour des raisons
de commodité c'est souvent le samedi que
ces votes ont lieu ils sont donc
possibles
ils sont aussi possibles par
correspondance et tout le monde
j'insiste peut voter cela dit loin de la
grosse rumeur de la politique à l'école
ya les gens qui font tout pour préserver
ce qu'ils ont et qui est important pour
eux je veux parler des 80 18 habitants
de verges
un petit village du jura à paris on
appelle ça l'école sauvage mais là bas
on veut simplement garder la classe
c'est un petit village il n'y a que
douze élèves
le nombre à partir duquel on peut avoir
une institutrice mais n'a pas été nommé
il ya des tracasseries administratives
ce qui avait été décidé pour verges
c'était le regroupement pédagogique
c'est à dire que les enfants avec le
ramassage scolaire aller à l'école dans
une autre commune mais les parents
refusent et 2 instituteur en retraite
ont accepté de prendre la classe en main
reportage marie le rhône
et oui l'école si d'avis et la bouée de
sauvetage de tous les villages qui se
meurt ici pour vivre on a choisi
l'illégalité
on les attend crier sa fille mais de
l'avis ni sortie saute court on ça nous
amuse ça nous disent prêts à ça vous
savez c'est comme l'église fallait
autrefois et ben voila si la preuve plus
de ça c'est fini mais c'est la menace et
la mort la mort du village anjra
l'administration décide de fermer
l'école ils ne sont plus que huit
écoliers il suffirait de 12 pour
maintenir le poste le jour de la rentrée
surprise ils seront bien 12 à se
présenter devant une école fermée par
réflexe pédagogique 2 instituteur en
retraite accepte bénévolement de faire
la classe mais depuis l'administration
refuse de reconnaître les 12 élèves et
déclare l'école y les gars je suis au
courant de la pédagogie et la classe que
je fais c'est pas une classe de
l'ancienne cantine classes une classe à
la pointe de la pédagogie
j'applique les instructions officielles
qui corresponde avec la seule manière de
faire que nous avons fait jusqu'à
maintenant
l'école sauvage puisque sa piscine école
soma nous l'appelons une école publique
avec des instituteurs publie diplômés
retraités mais c'est une classe public
je sais bien aloi lecaussin alors menace
de suppression des allocations
familiales et enfants ne sont pas
scolarisés et pour le temps vous allez
avoir des comptes aux gens font
travailler les colis s'amuse pas ils
sont pas dans les rues non ma foi voilà
où est l'illégalité
une situation qui apparaît comme sa
paradoxale
on ferme une école on supprime un poste
alors que l'on sait par ailleurs qu'il
ya ne serait-ce que des maîtres
auxiliaires qui attendent un emploi dans
le département du jura comme ailleurs en
france du reste je ne crois pas qu'il y
ait en ce moment aucun instituteurs
formés dans une école normale est
titulaire d'un certificat d'aptitude
professionnelle donc remplissant les
conditions pour pouvoir enseigner qu'ils
soient chômeurs la rigueur de
l'administration a créé le désarroi ici
il n'ya plus rien plus de commerce plus
de café plus de curé et peut-être
bientôt plus d'école mais comme c'est la
vie du pays quoi c'est pas ça pas
d'école et à projets de lotissements
comment voulez vous que des jeunes
ménages de s'installer ici c'est pas
d'école seulement câble il faut qu'on
est né qu on se battra jusqu'au bout et
sommes bien déterminés même le populaire
c'est vrai on voit bien ici les enfants
l'école c'est la vie et comme dirait un
confrère il ya sûrement quelque chose à
faire pour ceux de verges
demain au conseil des ministres le
projet de loi d'indemnisation des
rapatriés
ces derniers attendent depuis longtemps
ce texte qui reconnaîtra le droit à
l'indemnisation et qui sera constituée
droit qui sera constitué par des
certificats des titres ayant une valeur
financière et qui serviront notamment à
garantir les emprunts le remboursement
des certificats d'indemnisation
commencera dès 79 d'abord en faveur des
personnes âgées
ces orientations avait été présenté
après un déjeuner à l'elysée avec les
représentants des associations de
rapatriés mais les détails du projet de
loi et bien ils ne seront connus que
demain ce soir on doit tout de même se
souvenir qu'en 62 en 1962 il ya eu un
million de rapatrier et que c'est avec
des fortunes diverses qu'ils ont refait
leur vie en métropole patrick de carolis
en 62 lyon marseille nice et tout le
languedoc deviennent de nouvelles terres
d'adoption pour un million de rapatrier
chaque famille s'empresse alors de
rassembler tous les documents des biens
immobiliers laissé en algérie on parle
déjà d'indemnisation 190 mille dossiers
seront déposés à la niche comme l'
agence nationale d'indemnisation des
français d'outre-mer la loi du 15
juillet 1970 en réglera 90000 le reste
traîne et en 74 quand ils arrivent au
pouvoir le président de la république
décide de prendre en main ce lourd
dossier pour le mener à terme
aujourd'hui c'est chose presque faite
puisqu'un projet de loi d'indemnisation
sera soumis au parlement à la mi
novembre
il permettra de régler 95% des dossiers
déposés par les rapatrier les personnes
âgées pour en retrouver en cinq ans la
totalité de la patrimoine c'est un point
important puisque 40% d'entre elles en
plus de 65 ans nous nous sommes demandé
ce que sont devenus tous ces rapatriés
ou plus exactement 6 15 ans après il
avait oui ou non réussi leur réinsertion
non aux prix de revient ne permettent
pas d'acheter
tu peux toujours servi cet industriel
qui avec l'accent pieds-noirs marchand
quelques centimes sur le kilo de
sardines c'est dominique mère curieux
enjoint sur 102 quand il débarque à
marseille
il doit tout reprendre à zéro il a 37
ans très peu d'argent et se lance dans
la poissonnerie détail à celle d'algérie
j'avais ma mercedes et une 404 que j'ai
vendu pour racheter les parts du bateau
à la ciotat et j'ai roulé pendant trois
ans avec une deux jours pour connaître
je conversais les équations je ne
prendrai avec et 14 ans après la petite
camionnette il devenu une grande et
vichy la petite communauté la
poissonnerie sont venus bien sûr grande
industrie puisque matin je dirige une
société qui fait plus d'un milliard
chiffre d'affaires avec 80 personnes
finalement je retrouve mon métier
d'algérie à 53 ans dominique mercure you
fait partie des rapatriés qui ont réussi
la réinsertion
il a oublié l'intérêt de papa ou presque
en tout cas les souvenirs ne sortent
jamais de l'album de famille pour louis
galice est différent chez lui on ne sait
pas très bien si des merguez le couscous
font partie du folklore ou d'un rite
sacré à la question pensez-vous avoir
réussi réponse non son lopin de terre
n'est pas devenu le grand domaine qui
laisse les réponses et les sensations
j'ai reprise mois en 65 et je rêvais 663
pour démarrer à 0 c'est déjà un problème
en plus de ça maintenant sa mévente des
20 alors c'est pas c'est pas vrai du
tout franchement parler s'il fallait
rembourser les prêts seraient
impossibles parce que non franchement
c'est pas envie vote
c'est ce qu'ils ont envie vote il faut
vivre il faut travailler il faut payer
les matériels et photo p
le jour il faudra rembourser les prêts
mais je vous dis dans les trois-quarts
qui s'est surtout dans les professions
libérales que les succès furent les plus
nombreux mais combien de réussie en bien
l'échec
aucun chiffre précis avoue jean claude
narcy pour les autres nouvelles de ce
journal raymond barre était cet après
midi devant le groupe de réformateurs de
l'assemblée nationale il a rappelé que
c'est en janvier que le gouvernement
indiquera les objectifs d'action en vue
des prochaines élections législatives
le premier ministre a précisé que les
candidats qui apporteront leur soutien à
ces objectifs auront l'appui du
gouvernement et cela sans exclusive le
haut fourneau de thionville sera fermée
le 19 décembre dont juste avant noël
c'est officiel la direction a assuré que
les 500 ouvriers concernés ne seront pas
licenciés mais qu'ils suivront l'année
prochaine des stages de formation
cette fermeture est une illustration de
la crise on souffre actuellement la
sidérurgie mondiale sont en cause les
débouchés car depuis le ralentissement
général des économies des pays
industrialisés
ce secteur est en surproduction les
commandes ont chuté de 20% environ
alors que de nouveaux producteurs au
moyen très moderne se sont installés sur
le marché international adolfo suarez et
tous les dirigeants des partis
politiques espagnols ont signé
aujourd'hui l'accord économique qu'ils
avaient conclu mercredi dernier il
s'agit de mesures destinées à juguler
sur une période de deux ans la crise que
traverse actuellement l'espagne blocage
des prix et des salaires
réforme de l'impôt avec ponction
supplémentaire sur les catégories les
plus favorisées
le ministre syrien des affaires
étrangères monsieur qu'adam est sorti
indemne d'un attentat perpétré sur
l'aéroport d'abu dhabi en revanche le
secrétaire d'état aux affaires
étrangères des émirats arabes unis a été
mortellement blessée par des hommes
armés qui ont ouvert le feu l'un d'entre
eux d'ailleurs et arrêtez monsieur
qu'adama la baraka puisque c'est le
deuxième attentat auquel il échappe
le synode des évêques ferme ses portes à
la fin de la semaine d'ici là les 22
participants les 200 participants
parlant voteront à document destiné au
pape et qui rassemble les grands axes de
la discussion
une chose est certaine les prélats
réaffirmeront leur attachement à
l'enseignement oral du catéchisme les
adresseront une lettre à tous les
catholiques réaffirmant l'importance
d'une éducation de la fois chez les
jeunes
norodom sihanouk ray apparaît sur la
scène politique cambodgien
après 18 mois des clipse la radio
nationale a même cité son nom à propos
de lettre qu'il a adressée à monsieur
paul potes
le secrétaire général du parti
communiste cambodgien les programmes des
trois chaînes de télévision à niveau
diffusé ce soir sur l'ensemble de
l'ouest de la france
la qualité de diffusion sera inégale
jusqu'à la reconstruction totale de la
station de pré-en-pail 2 % de la
redevance et le coût des attentats
contre tdf en 1977
d'après l'estimation de gens plus est le
rapporteur du budget de la radio et de
la télévision sénat monsieur plus l
accepte également le relèvement de la
redevance en 1978 et souhaite une
meilleure harmonisation des programmes
ainsi que la rediffusion des émissions
de qualité et il demande aux sociétés
télévision de renoncer retransmission
des manifestations sportives
quand la publicité alcool tabac est trop
présente sur les stades
après le français autour du paquebot
renaissance d'être vendus d'ici à la fin
de l'année et un acheteur étranger
également c'est ce que précise
aujourd'hui la nouvelle compagnie des
paquebots
l'explosion d'un immeuble de chambéry ce
matin a fait cinq blessés graves
les pompiers ont eu des difficultés pour
dégager les victimes des décombres en
raison de la pluie diluvienne qui
s'abattait sur la région
les dégâts sont très importants et une
enquête est ouverte pour déterminer les
causes de l'explosion
à chambéry on parle ce soir de fuite de
gaz
les prix de l'humour noir ont été
décernés pour le théâtre à maurice
toesca et pour les bandes dessinées à
jacques tardi pour le savant fou édité
chez casterman
les célèbres all blacks sont en france
pour une longue durée ou une longue
tournée qui durera demain qui débutera
du moins demain à brive face à une
sélection française
les rugbymans néo zélandais disputeront
cette rencontre au total dont deux test
matches le 11 novembre à toulouse et le
19 au parc des princes pour la france
ces rencontres serviront à former le 15
appelés à disputer le prochain tournoi
des cinq nations
les concurrents de la course autour du
monde ont quitté le cap ce matin pour la
deuxième étape qui va les conduire à
auckland
si le grand favori reste le landais
flyers premiers au classement
deux des quatre bateaux français ont
encore toutes leurs chances
d'abord gauloise de arrivé troisième et
puis neptune vous savez le bateau de
notre envoyé spécial est notre ami
bernard de guy qui compte bien sur les
mers du sud pour rattraper le temps
perdu lors de la première étape
oui c'est sûr il va y arriver il nous
l'a promis le temps le temps oui légère
baisse des températures aujourd'hui mais
tout de même encore très confortable
pour la saison entre 14 et 21 degrés
demain le beau temps est annoncé mais
seulement après la dissipation des
brouillards matinaux le ciel restera
peut être couvert dans le nord et l'est
dans le nord-est et l'est cependant sur
les alpes et les régions méridionales on
attend pluies et orages en début de
journée il pleuvra moins fort ensuite
dans l'ensemble températures minimales
en baisse maximale sans changement tout
près de paris dans le val d'oise à
écourt approximativement entre paris et
chantilly il existe désormais un musée
exceptionnel dans un cadre que je vous
recommande le musée de la renaissance
toutes les collections de cette grande
époque la renaissance que le musée de
cluny ne pouvait exposer faute de place
on trouvait le cadre qui leur convenait
dans ce château d'ecouen rénové avec
raffinement et qui était l'ancien
pensionnat de la légion d'honneur
c'est andré malraux qui en 69 avait eu
l'idée de transférer au château de au
château d'ecouen transformé par dont le
château d'ecouen en musée valéry giscard
d'estaing a inauguré ce matin sans doute
pour souligner l'importance qu'il
attache à l'amélioration et la
modernisation des musées en france
il a confirmé d'ailleurs un projet de
musée
du 19e siècle à la gare d'orsay à paris
mais pour l'instant visite on est quoi
ce en vaut la peine
après des années d'efforts le château
d'ecouen est devenu ce matin musée
national de la renaissance à 20 km de
paris il fournit un cadre exceptionnel
aux collections de la renaissance
française mise en réserve depuis la
guerre au musée de cluny
désormais tout est regroupé ici ainsi
que d'autres trésors dans la clarté et
la cohérence et c'est cet événement que
le président de la république est venu
saluer ainsi que le travail des
restaurateurs
les visiteurs pourront admirer un riche
mobilier et broderies peintes et
cheminées peindre ou sculpter les
connexions des mots et surtout la
fameuse d'épicerie de david longue de 75
m haute de 4 mètres et qu'on n'avait pas
vu depuis 40 ans
bref une rencontre avec tous ceux qui
évoquent le cadre de vie d'un grand
seigneur du 16e siècle montre à l'heure
actuelle que les le nombre des visiteurs
dans les musées ne cesse de s'accroître
dans les proportions tout à fait
considérable et n'ont aucun intérêt du
public alors il faut ensuite actuelle
notre budget soit accessible au point de
vue des heures d'ouverture au point de
vue de la présentation d'ailleurs deux
des collections elle-même ce qui fait
qu'il faut dans une certaine mesure
améliorer et moderniser notre
présentation va faire de l'user et le
gouvernement va examiner dans quelques
semaines projet de louhans programme
mais voyons sur plusieurs années un
grand effort national en faveur de nos
musées de passion en compétents
l'équipement est pas sans pouvoir
présenter à tous les superbes
collections de la france voilà je vous
souhaite de visiter beaucoup de musées
bien entretenu ce n'est pas le cas
partout mais si j'ai bien compris ça va
venir
bonne soirée à tous au nom de toute
l'équipe de tf1 actualité dernier
journal avec jean pierre pernaut
vers 23h40 merci